[Music]
can i show you another comedic genius
because i want to do i want to do a
segment because there's so much stuff
that we can do
merch tell me can we do a segment called
what's wrong with seth rogen
okay what happened now this is his
latest video it's a little weed tray
it's yeah it's only 17 seconds watch
what
no
what's he doing
may i ask the question of course what's
wrong with seth rogen thank you thank
you look there's so
there's so much of this out there by the
way of what's wrong with seth rogen
what's wrong with seth rogen like
we have i.t
hey i t you don't have to make a whole
song just make this like a quick jingle
right exactly what's wrong with seth
rogen yes that's it
it only needs to be 10 seconds
look at his nails why does he have nails
pressed what's going on
why does he have nails on
also
can we stop
like with the weed is my entire identity
bro you're like in your [__] 40s now
exactly
i mean it's not even illegal anymore
it's not even like
remember when like weed was cool yeah
legal and it was like oh [__] you got
some weed dude
right and now it's like he's still just
doing the
look dude weed yeah
cares
group is back
in lilac and orange
what
i mean
what's wrong with seth rogen
yeah it's just
i don't know man the fact that he's
still doing the like her bro
look check it out i'm smoking it's the
[__] it's the sam hyde thing dude i'm
smoking weed
this is good weed
it's the only thing he has
it i really is pathetic
here let me show you one of his other
videos
let me show you one of his other videos
[Music]
look man i'm not 17 years old anymore
this isn't
funny
or cool no it's an old it's an old it
seems like it's like an old man at a
grateful dead concert making a video
like i don't
what's what are you doing seth rogen
by the way i did post in our show links
the the bit it's only like 17 seconds
but this this summarizes seth rogen to a
t
intended show links okay yes yeah this
is this is [__] i remember this
yeah this is this is him in a nutshell
right here
oh that's some good weed that's some
good weed bro
dude this is some good weed
dude this weed is so good
yup
that's seth rogen in a nutshell
summarized in 17 seconds
man it's just like really [__] sad
like
i i mean i remember liking his [__] i
really do and and
i don't know what he's doing now but